voters be damned Democrat Elites are
hell-bent on pushing an 80 year old Joe
Biden in 2024
axios reporting on the gaping divide or
aperture
between Party leaders and the actual
people who ultimately decide elections
Biden's numbers across the board are in
the crapper another aperture
but that's not stopping top Democrats
from getting on the Biden train I'm
going to say it I think part of it is
that we now have to make sure the
American people they've read what we
have done yeah but they haven't seen it
yeah and this second year is going to be
a year of implementing getting the good
things that we did out he's got a record
of delivering for people at this point
polls are just you like them or you
don't like them it's not a match-up when
we see a matchup I think people are
going to see this president has
delivered and that's why you see so many
of my colleagues and me getting ready to
to help him win re-election and while
the big guy hasn't officially announced
his re-election bid it is looking
imminent I say the union is over when
are we going to hear the the big speech
the Biden Harris 2024
announcements as you know I am I am
limited and what I can say I can't talk
about politics I am covered by by the
hatchback but what I can say is repeat
what the president has said many times
is that he intends to run I leave it
there
all right Harold uh let's go back in
time a couple of months perhaps where
you were 100 confident that he was
running and we laughed at you we mocked
you even behind your back no yes we may
we you were the laughing stock of this
company for weeks and now it looks like
we have egg on our face and you have the
last laugh do you believe he's
definitely running
um I think he will and I think whenever
someone tells me they're going to do
something I generally take them at their
word so I think he's going to run I
think president Trump is going to stay
in this race uh I think Governor
Huckabee Sanders who gave a formidable
speech the other night and she she made
it clear in her remarks that it was time
for a change so I listened to all of
this and I you know I gotta look the
Congress when I was 26 people said I was
too young so I'm not going to be an
aegist if people want a president that
is uh where President Biden is or
president Trump is and we certainly had
one in President Reagan the policy
Acuity was right for President Reagan
which is why he got elected and
reelected I think what voters want most
is problem solving uh and if you've it
condition position yourself and you
execute on being a problem solver
um you can win I don't care what your
age is and President Biden I think is
going to uh has some things to to tick
off as he announces his re-election and
he's got the next year I think to deal
with some really really tough issues
including the border and if he's able to
do that and successfully I think he will
be hard not only to beat the Democratic
primary but he'll be hard to beat in a
general election as well judge what do
you say with egg on your face I think
that's a I mean to say yeah you know
it's tasty
uh what what do you say to Harold as he
gloats over there temporarily before
okay what I say to him is that and 62
percent of the Americans think that
Biden has achieved little or nothing in
his first two years
I like my homes too yeah oh okay all
right and but you know what I think is
significant the big thing is that people
are people are saying you know is to all
these two you know we just he's he's not
connect he's cognitively declining and
all that other stuff do you remember
when Reagan ran for his second term do
you know how old he was when he ran for
a second term he was 73. I mean this guy
um is going to be 83 10 years older I
mean and and you know so I think that's
a concern and I you know what I also
think this thing with China and that
spycraft I think that's going to have an
incredible impact on what people think
of our commander-in-chief how he handled
it how we let it just crisscross the
country how he wouldn't come out and
face America and come out and talk about
it so I agree with Harold I think the
Border as more people move into
different parts of the country who you
know rushed the Border or invaded the
country I think there's going to be a
lot of problems for Joe Biden you know
it's like two years away Jesse and we've
already seen a marked decline in Biden's
uh uh I don't know cognition
and so it could get really really bad
yeah but it doesn't matter no because
he's shown how to win elections if
you're a Democrat you don't campaign and
you let the media and the minions Do
Your Dirty Work you don't focus on
voters you focus on ballots and you talk
about unity and then when you get into
office you don't talk to anybody you
don't talk to reporters you stay off
social media and if you do have to say
something before you get onto Marine one
you just say yes or you say no or you
say my people are briefing me and we'll
decide soon
that is the game plan you don't have to
do anything to be a Democratic president
you just read whatever notes your staff
tells you call on this person don't call
on that person or call on nobody and
then you go home to Delaware you just
stay out of the picture because every
American is on their phones all day so
if you can create a nice gentle
impression on their phones
sometimes not an impression at all then
you're just cool with the voters don't
do anything controversial don't do
anything bold don't take responsibility
for anything take credit for everything
good that happens and that's your Mo
because everybody's here so it's that's
the plan what do you think Dana I feel
like if you read all these polls but
also just the stories where they're
where reporters have actually gone out
to talk to democratic voters read a
story today where quote after quote of
people that are Democrats all across the
country
unsure he should run again and the
Democratic party and the White House
have closed the aperture on the
Democratic voters they're ignoring them
but here's how I know that he's going to
run why
so Bernie Sanders has his book coming
out and he's let it be known that uh
he's very comfortable Biden runs again
he's probably not going to run for
president again so he knows it's over
for him and he's comfortable with that
why because Biden won the election but
the progressives won the war and so
they're comfortable they're like yeah
we're good we've got the guy that we
want there you go
it's all coming together hi winner Brian
Kilmeade I want you to do me a favor I
want you to click to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page this is the only
way that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now